[Music]
I went to all these amazing dinners
before the Oscars I met Danny Elfman who
said you want to get it but still I was
unsure and whole of India was cheering I
would felt like a gladiator
[Music]
and the Oscar goes to AR Rahman Slumdog
Millionaire Wendy announce my name for
the score I was like is this real or is
it a dream and because I had to perform
next I was like hey I don't react just
be like the Zen more don't mess up your
performance
my speech was not prepared I said I'll
go by the flow maximum I would say thank
you and go off but when I was sitting
there I was watching Penelope Baker's
speaking Spanish
thank you so much it looks like oh
that's cool I want to share something in
Tamil which says
that means all perfect places belongs to
God Alone
is from a holy book it's a promise from
God thank you that if you remember in
the Happy Times I'll remember you have a
sad time so that was the happiest time
of my own life and I wanted to remember
the God was common to all of us and the
Oscar goals too
the second time when they announced my
name for the best song the essence of
the film which is about optimism and the
power of Hope in our lives I had said in
the speech that the essence of the film
is optimism and hope because the world
was going through that depression
economic depression and some rock
millenna was done in a way that anybody
who sees it would feel high all my life
I've had a choice of hate and love I
chose love and I'm here God bless some
people are misinterpreted that statement
over some religion and this and that
which is not true this is the state of
every artist in the world and that's
what makes them the artist they want to
give and love is about giving not taking
after I got those because I put it in my
hand baggage
and the security when I was getting to
India they said can you wait and there
were almost like 100 people in the in
the security check so the officer took
these two was a look what I have and
everybody went to Gaga they were just oh
my God